before I start I do have some
interactive demos later on so if you
want to grab the URL if you like playing
with sliders on your own you can do that
I'll just link to the slides but then
there's more links later on all right so
first real quick a little bit about me
I'm trained as an experimental
psychologist right now a postdoc at
Cincinnati Children's Hospital in the
division of Sports Medicine and that's
where the research I'll tell you about
today came from all my way out the
co-founding a soccer analytic startup in
Spain I'd love to share more about it
but it'd have to be offline so please
come talk to me we're probably hiring
soon all right so let's jump in what
we'll do today I'm going to tell you
some theories so a little bit different
than usual pie data talk but I think it
sets up the Python stuff that will come
later the theory of direct perception
some philosophy of mind I don't talk
about dynamical systems and how to model
them and how to explore these systems
specifically using folk' applications
and then I'll do some massive
simulations they're mastered for me
maybe not mastered for some of you but
master from anything I've done before
all right so if you took intro to
psychology or cognitive science in
undergrad maybe you encountered this
type of problem before we get a
rectangle on our retinal image how do we
know what shape really produced it right
it's ambiguous it could be any of these
different parallelograms and
traditionally the answer is we make some
guesses we maybe have some assumptions
from our knowledge about the world we
get some hints do some computation and
we take a stab at it
and this leads to a view of the mind
where the order of operations goes
something like this we receive some
sensory input it's really bad since
replay doesn't tell us a lot of
information we have to process it apply
some computation and the objective of
this computation is to construct an
internal model of the world and once we
have this internal model we can use it
to plan our actions
which we then execute this it's a way of
thinking about cognition where and
perception and specifically where we're
not really in contact with the external
world we're only really in contact with
this model of the world that we build in
our heads and so we kind of have these
low five sensors we're like trapped in
our brains we've got like some levers
and pulleys and that's really our only
way of interacting with the world and so
that's interact in direct perception
still pretty mainstream view in
psychology now the alternative is direct
perception obviously it had some
philosophical antecedents but really was
made scientifically viable by JJ Gibson
in the 50s 60s and 70s all right Gibson
reframe the problem says why we focus on
the retinal image that's not the input
to the system instead we should look at
the optic array all the light that's
bouncing around the room at any moment
and we sample this array by a moving
point of observation as we move through
the world so we have these angles these
visual angles two objects that change in
reliable systematic ways and these
movements more generally create what we
call optic flow how each each point in
the environment changes in the visual
field and there's reliable information
in the optic flow for example a
stationary point tells you you're on a
collision course and of course this is
being used for autonomous vehicles one
other things they also reframed the
objective of perception maybe it's not
necessarily to construct a 3d
representation of the world but rather
just to discover the possibilities for
action so you know how many meters why
the doorway is we just need to know it's
the kind of opening that you might be
able to walk through also we reframe the
input it's richer than we thought it was
we reframe the objective it's easier
than we thought it was so we don't need
hints we don't need cues but we get math
irregularities are invariants that
specify the state of the world and
specify our relationship to it in a
reliable one-to-one manner doesn't
require any further processing so good
news if Gibson is right we're not
trapped in our heads after all and that
our job as perceptual scientists is to
kind of figure out what are these
invariants what was the information that
we're using to guide our actions so that
brings me to perception in action take a
traditional problem in this area of how
to catch a fly ball so how do we know
how to get to the right place at the
right time to catch a projectile
now the computational approach right
would say we observe the location of the
ball its velocity we have some internal
model of physics based on some
assumptions that allows us to compute
the future trajectory you get to the
right place at the right time by
executing some motor program easy right
well there's an even easier way if we
consider the optic flow pattern that the
fly ball makes from a moving point of
observation in particular if you move in
order to cancel out any optical
acceleration so the visual angle of the
ball don't let it accelerate you'll get
to the right place at the right time so
if it's accelerating upward you have to
accelerate backward if it's accelerating
downward you have to move forward if you
do that it's just a moment-to-moment
strategy doesn't require any prediction
if we do that you'll end up in the right
place at at the right time well I guess
at some point you have to actually catch
it or it'll just hit you in the eyeball
and so more generally then we like to
think about movement and perception as
linked or interaction as as
intrinsically linked so movement
generates information via optic flow at
least for vision and then this
information parametrize is the movement
so it doesn't make sense let's talk
about the perceptional system and the
action system that we have to think
about perception and action together but
I'm a I'm a math nerd so I like the
formalism
so we think about the environment as a
dynamical system governed by the laws of
physics and we try to figure out one of
the laws of control that govern the
agents behavior and these control laws
are function of the information which is
itself a function of the state of the
environment and then the environment is
modified by the actions of the invite of
the agent via forces and then based on
some ideas about self-organizing systems
there emerges some kind of stable
behavioral pattern from this interaction
and we study that using behavioral
dynamics which is what I will share with
you next sorry
switch gears a little bit show you some
dynamical models
first one is the hkb model so this is a
coupled oscillator model and what I find
really cool about this is its domain in
general so it doesn't matter what
oscillators you have it describes two
metronomes couple physically by an
unstable surface describes crickets
chirping and synchrony and this is a
classic experiment in perception action
coordinated limb movements or finger
finger wagging and even if you have
participants in rocking chairs
ask them to synchronize by looking at
each other good thing with all these
cases you get the same kind of global
patterns of the possible outcomes so as
long as there's some kind of coupling it
can be physical coupling by vibrations
can be informational coupling by
perception or neural coupling you know
through the through one person's body
and here's the actual model and perhaps
the reason it's so general it's just two
terms of a Fourier series so I've never
seen it dynamical model before you got
the state variable on the left or
specifically the rate of change or the
state variable and so what the model
tells you is how does the state of the
system change as a function of the
current state so in this case it's a
one-dimensional system there's one state
variable in this case it's relative
phase so when relative phase is zero
that's in phase movements so like your
limbs moving together for example and
then at PI it would be anti phase so
moving in the opposite direction and
based on the current phase of the system
the relation between the two oscillators
you get a sense of how the phase is
changing at the moment and in this
formulation of the model we have two
parameters coupling parameter B and
Delta Omega which is the difference
between the frequencies so this lets
this model when you have two oscillators
that prefer to run at different speeds
alright so I'm gonna switch now to
actual demo here and try to walk you
through this so we see in the top is the
phase portrait so this is just plotting
the equation of the system we got the
state variable its relative phase on the
x axis and its rate of change on the y
axis and it's a one dimensional system
so you can imagine its movement as just
moving back and forth along the x axis
the state is just a position on the x
axis so wherever you start there's only
two things that can happen you move
right or you move left and the the curve
tells you how you're going to move so
for example you can see the cursor yep
so if you start over here the rate of
change is positive you move right you
end up here if you start over here rate
of change is negative who's left
you end up over here in this same spot
so anywhere where this curve crosses the
x-axis is a fixed point she was starting
on a fixed point you'll stay there if
it's a filled circle
it's an attractor if you start near it
you'll end up there the open circles
then are repellers if you are exactly on
it and there's no noise you'll stay
there but as soon as you come off of it
you'll head in one of the other
directions and then on the bottom
another way of looking at the same
system is by the system potential and
this is just a negative integral of the
equation and now the attractors are
valleys and the repellers are Peaks so
in this way of representing the system
you can think about from wherever you
start even think about ball rolling down
a slope so it'll end up in one of the
valleys and now what's interesting is
how the system changes as we change the
parameters so first how its how its set
up now we've got two stable behavioral
patterns so 0 and 2pi they're the same
it's a circular variable that's stable
at 0 or a 2 pi down here and then at pi
that's also stable
then if we change this coupling
parameter let's see what happens if you
look at I'll go back and forth a few
times so you're going to talk we look at
the bottom so you get the the valley
turns into a peak and vice versa or you
get one fixed point kind of splitting
into three same thing really
so now that when when you're down in
this regime you just have one stable
pattern and then see what the other one
does when you add this difference in
frequencies okay this is some asymmetry
in the system now and actually changes
the relative phase that's stable is near
in phase but not exactly in phase and
that's the kind of pattern that you'll
observe now the nice thing about
dynamics is there's some pretty simple
rules since it's a continuous line you
have to have if you have two attractors
you have to have a repeller in the
middle for example and as a result
there's only so many different things
that can happen so there's only so many
different ways you can transition from
one type of behavior to another you can
you can have like like this one where
you get kind of two fixed points coming
together and eliminating each other and
you can get this kind of transition
where one six point becomes three so
you're really limited repertory any
one-dimensional system long as this
continuous equation those are the only
different things that can happen all
right
so step back for a minute I want to
check out the code if you're interested
but want to definitely shout out to all
the libraries that make this possible so
bouquet apps is a huge part of it makes
it really easy to make this kind of
interaction and then simple it's great
because you can interact with the
equation symbolically and then when you
want to evaluate it convert it to an
umpire function and then that lets you
do things like the pretend
in this case is the negative integral as
I mentioned so you can let simple handle
that for you so if I wanted to change
the equation add another parameter from
a different version of the model it's
pretty easy to do that I can solve for
the roots so you so what's the pond you
get the symbolic computation but you can
also still use it for fast numerical
evaluation all right for the next one so
here we have a van der Pol oscillator
this is a type of nonlinear oscillator
it does have some physiological
implications but let's not talk about
that so in two dimensions we can think
about the state of the system right as
any point in the XY axis in the
cartesian plane here and then a
trajectory is like a curve through that
space so let's start with okay- you can
see the phase portrait kind of shows you
any point you would start out with
direction there you're going to go next
which is really all the system is
defined by and then I have it set up
thanks to bouquet where you click on the
system and it doesn't simulation alright
so here we have some damping going on
with this oscillator it's going around
but it eventually ends up in this fixed
point in the middle or if you start
further outside here you zoom out to
infinity alright let's go the other way
so now we K when K is positive here we
get a stable oscillation that's kind of
self-sustained
if you start inside it you'll go back
out start outside of it you'll head back
in and so in two dimensions you're gonna
fix point attractors you can also have
what's called a limit cycle so it's
still an attractor the eventual final
state of the system but it's a set of
point instead of just one point and
again in two dimensions there's a
limited repertoire of different things
that can happen so it harder to see
those transitions and this app that you
can get you know one fixed point turning
into a limit cycle and vice versa you
know different ways that the look that
the attractors can interact with each
other but there's only like a handful of
different things that can happen in any
two-dimensional system and what what
dynamics really are useful it's not like
some of the other models we talk about
here at PI data not necessary for making
a prediction or explaining what's about
to happen next although it does do that
but it's really what I find it useful
for is describing the all the
possibilities that a system has so in
this case we know there's really two
regimes that can be in it can have the
fixed part in the middle or it can have
a limit cycle attractor with a
continuous oscillation you can kind of
see what the transition looks like
between those two things and that's why
I like to do many simulations sort of
just one get a sense of all the
possibilities of the system one more
well point out the implementation
details again I'm using sin pi and now
to do the simulations using Syfy's solve
IVP solve initial value problem which
takes takes the differential equations
and just runs them through again not too
hard once you have the equation
one more this is the steering done in
this model this is the main model I've
been working with so this describes how
a person or or an animal or any any
locomotor creature is not getting
through an environment avoiding
obstacles and trying to reach a goal in
the equation here describes the angular
acceleration of the heading so you can
it's basic an analogy to an angular
spring so you can imagine there's a
spring pulling you're heading toward the
direction of the goal pushing you away
from obstacles and so we have in this
case it's a four dimensional system when
you write it as a series of first-order
equations you have heading your rate of
change of heading you have x and y
alright one more
so now if the four dimensional system as
I said so here on the Left we have a
phase portrait which is in this case the
two-dimensional slice of this four
dimensional space I only have time to
talk about exactly how to interpret that
let's focus on the plot on the right
which is just a top-down view of right
now we got an agent and obstacle and the
goal I'll select this tool now thanks to
bouquet we can move these things around
this is really easy to set up and let's
just see what happens so I have a set up
right now when I press him it just does
eight equally spaced starting
trajectories and then simulates the
trajectory from there going around the
obstacle to a goal I can double click on
the plot and add another obstacle we can
kind of see the possibilities there so
you can kind of experiment with how
close to have to get for example how
close so if you get to that gap before
it actually takes it there we go how
close you have to get before it always
takes it so these kinds of things are
useful for designing the environments
and the experiments which I will show
you next and again it's not a very
useful for exactly what the person will
do like in this case actually it's
climbing and one of the simulations but
it's for understanding all the
possibilities for action when does the
gap disappear when does it not become
the type of route that someone will
actually take and here I'm adding one
more tool from the senpai I'm compiling
the equation every time we had an
obstacle it's programmatically
generating the equation so he's adding
some more terms on to add other
repellers from the obstacle and
compiling that the for train so I've
been stimulated more quickly and then
still the simulation itself is with Syfy
alright I'll finally I'll show you some
data we collected in the lab there's no
simulations at least based on this data
so we have a augmented reality and
virtual reality laboratory and this
specific data is from a study we're
trying to design scenarios to train
young athletes to be more aware of their
surroundings to prevent unanticipated
collisions which are big source of
concussions so here this is augmented
reality that some product placement
that's the microsoft hololens
so that's projecting obstacles into the
lab space and then their task is to
dribble around them and then here's a VR
trial this is obviously for the
participants point of view in this case
there's no dribbling
there's trying to avoid the NPC's which
are trying to reach them you can see are
that cursor is showing our eye tracking
data so we have eye trackers embedded in
the headset which will try to understand
the scanning behavior is a big part of
unanticipated collisions also see the
safety features that stop sign wall to
make sure that in VR they don't get too
close to the actual physical wall all
right so here it's the final thing I'll
show you not really good scale for it
for the presentation sorry about that so
what I'm doing here this is the same
trial got the agent trajectories in the
white there and then the red are the
obstacles or the NPCs and here were
using simple to programmatically build
these equations in this case we have a
four dimensional system for each agent
in the scene including the NPC's in the
simulation at least they're guided by
the model and the questions are really
long you know they're treating the other
other NPCs as obstacles so you can just
generate that programmatically if you're
a masochist you can print it out it's
it's super long and crazy but anyways
all together that makes a twenty to
mention all dynamical system
and here we're performing 2500
simulations at each time step and it's a
different deterministic system so I'm
randomly varying the starting position
these time step and then using these hex
bins in order to see the likely future
positions and so that lets you
understand kind of where there's a
second solution that emerges for a
moment in this trial they don't they
kind of take the most printed solution
most of the way through you kind of see
when they're being funneled into one
trajectory when there's more options
open it runs in a few minutes on a
single core so there's still of course
more optimizations I could do it's not
parallelized yet but it really blows my
mind how far we've come thanks to really
all the open source projects that we use
so when these models were first being
made like 15 years ago what they would
do just to compare the model to the data
they were actually averaged all the data
they collected into one trajectory and
then simulated once and now not only are
we stimulating every trial individually
but we're doing this kind of thing for
each time step and we have some ideas in
mind for how to use this in our
environments for example to guide the
NPC's to funnel behavior in a certain
way pretty easier or more difficult
scenarios but we got to get that down to
real time first so that's that's the
next challenge yeah I guess that's about
it so thanks to Adam Kieffer my advisor
for getting grant money making this
possible
Brian McPherson program the unity
environments for AR VR and thanks to all
of you and thanks to everyone who made
all these libraries that were so lucky
to be able to use them
Thanks
[Applause]
yeah so now we have a few minutes for
questions I I didn't quite understand
how like those AR they are environments
related to the simulations that you had
were you trying to confirm that like
people behaved in the same manner as
your simulation um well so first of all
the model itself comes from similar VR
studies that were done by another lab
like 10-15 years ago as I said in our
case we're using the model to control
the NPCs and to break the likely outcome
so for example doing the simulation is
just from the starting position from a
range of initial conditions we can see
how many possible paths there are get a
sense of which which scenarios are more
difficult or easier get these different
metrics of them and the the end goal is
to design a training set that we can
kind of ramp up the difficulty to train
better collision avoidance behavior so
still the first stages in terms of that
end goal but it basically allows us to
assess the environment the models aren't
so there's similar models out there like
the social force model that do locomotor
trajectories this is the this one unlike
that the others is based on human data
but in this study were not actually
fitting it's already a fit model just
curious like how convinced are you that
this really explains how we behave I
think I think up to a certain point it's
pretty powerful I mean it gets more
philosophical I think when language gets
involved certainly that changes things
maybe that's why I stick to perception
in action I think as far as movement I
mean animals can do this stuff I think
it explains it pretty well
when you when you stop any OTE usually
there's numerical and CIPA and
stabilities yeah do you do if that was
simple or how do you handle that issue
yeah good question in this case it
didn't come up
I guess just cuz the equation actually
is fairly simple there's no there's no
like explosions of denominators or yeah
that could happen and other models I do
have another some other research I've
done on a braking model which is like
how do you how to use the optic flow to
avoid collisions in terms of controlling
acceleration is that one I did have
instability problems and I'm not really
an expert on all the numerix behind it I
mean that's the nice thing of all these
libraries you don't have to be but I
solved that problem by just kind of
going through all the different solvers
that Syfy offers until it found one that
worked reading the documentation to get
a sense of real why that's the case or
not
yes
it would thank you and I was just about
very cool visualizations what were there
any like novel results or paths paths
that were taken either by people or by
predicted by the by the like by the
optimized model that were very like
aberrant er yeah I certainly saw what
weird thing about the model is it is a
constant speed model so there's a speed
component that we could use but still
need some work so that creates weird
situations where it's like via two
people one person trying to evade
another person and they're both doing a
constant speed to get like weird leaps
so that doesn't happen of course also I
don't have the limits of the lab on here
so some of the simulations go pretty far
outside and then finally I guess
sometimes I think people just have the
participants cope with their own
strategies so for example pretty common
it all comes pretty fast and these guys
come at you quickly so some of the
participants is kind of run in a
direction the first direction they go
and then just try to beat them all
around the edge and I think that's the
strategy they're coming up with before
the trial is going to start
so I'll start like send the Molokini
anticipate oh maybe I'm not sure but
that's like I've tried to make it do
that good question
all right then thank you very much
thanks
[Applause]